EDUCATION FINANCE TODAY. IS THE.
.
FIX MATT HEARING FISCAL CRISIS
MANAGEMENT ASSISTANCE TEAM THE
ANNUAL UPDATE.
ON THE FISCAL HEALTH OF OUR.
SCHOOL DISTRICTS THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA.
AND I WANT TO.
.
BRING UP.
FIND FROM A THICK MAT FOR FOR
YOUR AND YOUR PRESENTATION.
WE ALSO WANT TO. TO WELCOME BACK
YEAH. BEAUTY AND I'M STILL GOING
TO BE EMBARRASSED BUT KATIE
KATIE HARD A MAN WHO'S JUST
JOINING US AFTER HER LEAVE IT
WITH HER AT. NEW BORN BABY.
AT HOME SO WELCOME BACK.
OKAY.
IT'S FINE.
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
SPECIAL GREETING TO A MEMBER
MEDINA WHO REPRESENTS MY.
MY HOME COMMUNITY.
WHERE I LIVE?
AND SO AS WE GREETED EACH OTHER
IT'S NICE TO SEE EACH OTHER.
OUTSIDE AN AIRPLANE OR OUTSIDE
THE AIRPORT WHICH IS USED TO
EVERY WE HAVE A GREAT
CONVERSATION.
UP MIKE FINE CHIEF EXECUTIVE
OFFICER OF OF THE STATE'S FISCAL
CRISIS AND MANAGEMENT ASSISTANCE
TEAM MY PLEASURE TO. UPDATE YOU
ON A NUMBER OF TOPICS TODAY.
WILL JUST GET STARTED AND.
GO RIGHT AND YOU YOU ALL HAVE
AN OUTLINE I'M JUST GONNA FOLLOW
THAT.
.
ON THAT OUTLINED IN START WITH A
TOPIC OF SCHOOL DISTRICTS
STABILITY. AS THE COMMITTEES
AWARE ON MAYBE THE AB TWELVE
HUNDRED PROCESS PROVIDES THAT
EACH SCHOOL DISTRICT FILE TO
INTERIM.
FINANCE REPORTS EACH YEAR WITH
THEIR RESPECTIVE COUNTY OFFICES
OF EDUCATION. RE REFER WE REFER
TO THESE REPORTS IS THE FIRST
AND SECOND IN ARMOR PORTS EACH
DISTRICT SELF CERTIFY AS A
POSITIVE QUALIFIED. OR NEGATIVE.
.
ED.
OR NEGATIVE CERTIFICATION THE
COUNTY OFFICE THAN REVIEWS OUT
REPORT AND SUPPORTING
DOCUMENTATION EITHER CONCURS OR
DOES NOT CONCUR.
WITH THAT SELF CERTIFICATION
AND THEN THE PROCESS MOVES ON TO
THE DEPARTMENT OF ED.
WITH RESPECT TO.
ONE FINAL REVIEW OF OF THAT
INFORMATION POSITIVE
CERTIFICATIONS A STATEMENT OF
THE DISTRICT WILL BE ABLE TO
MEET ITS INANCIAL OBLIGATIONS
FOR THE CURRENT PLUS TWO
SUBSEQUENT FISCAL YEARS.
QUALIFIED CERTIFICATION.
IT MEANS THAT THE DISTRICT MAY
NOT MEET ITS FINANCIAL
OBLIGATIONS FOR THE CURRENT AND
SUBSEQUENT FISCAL YEAR. AND A
NEGATIVE CERTIFICATION MEANS OF
THE DISTRICT WILL NOT MEET.
ITS FINANCIAL OBLIGATIONS FOR
THE CURRENT AND NEXT SUBSEQUENT
YEARS SO IT'S A TWO YEAR WINDOW
ON NEGATIVE AS OPPOSED TO THE
THE THREE YEAR WINDOW FOR BOTH
POSITIVE AND QUALIFIED.
THE OFFICIAL RESULTS OF THE
FIRST INTERIM ARE SHOWN IN YOUR
MATERIALS.
IN THE OUTLINE AND JUST BRIEFLY
WILL TALK ABOUT THOSE ALTHOUGH
THERE NOW THAT IS NOW DATED
INFORMATION FROM DECEMBER. ON
THE WE HAVE UPDATED INFORMATION
I'LL SHARE WITH YOU BUT I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT TO KNOW.
KIND OF WHERE THE THE OFFICIAL
DATA RESTS AT THIS POINT FROM
DECEMBER.
THERE WERE FORTY TWO QUALIFIED
DISTRICTS UP FROM THIRTY ONE A
YEAR EARLIER. IT'S NOTABLE THAT
SIX OF THOSE FORTY TWO WERE
ACTUALLY DOWNGRADES BY THE
COUNTY OFFICE OF ED SO IN THAT
EXAMPLE. THE DISTRICT SELF
CERTIFY POSITIVE.
AFTER THE COUNTY OFFICES REVIEW
THEY CHANGE THE CERTIFICATION TO
QUALIFIED IN DOWNGRADED I'M
BELIEVING THAT THEY DID NOT
MEET.
THE CRITERIA FOR POSITIVE.
THERE WERE FOUR NEGATIVES UP
FROM THREE THE PRIOR YEAR. ALL
FOR IN THIS IS BECOME KIND OF
ROUTINE ALL FOR DISTRICTS THAT
WERE NEGATIVE AT FIRST INTERIM
WERE NEW TO THE LIST.
AND THAT'S ACTUALLY REFLECTION
THE PROCESS WORKING.
DISTRICTS DON'T STAY ON A
NEGATIVE CERTIFICATION LIST VERY
LONG THERE'S A LOT OF RESOURCES
THAT COME. AND ENCIRCLED THEM.
FROM THE COUNTY OFFICE FROM ARE
NOT ORGANIZATION FROM FACT MATT
FROM CD EVE AND AND OTHERS AND
AND BASICALLY. I'M TRIAGE AND
GET THE DISTRICT BACK.
TO FISCAL HEALTH AND THEN THEY
MOVE BACK THROUGH THE
PROGRESSION QUALIFIED ON AND
BACK TO POSITIVE IS ALWAYS THE
GOAL.
ONE OF THOSE DISTRICTS PASADENA
FROM THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY.
BOB WHY THEY FILED A NEGATIVE
THEY WERE NOT NEGATIVE THEY USED
THIS PROCESS TO.
MORRIS A POLITICAL PROCESS TO
PUT SOME PRESSURE ON THEIR THEIR
OWN BOARD.
WHICH WAS NOT HOW THE SYSTEM
WAS DESIGNED TO WORK THERE'S A
DIFFERENT PROCESS TO DO THAT.
AND SO AT SECOND IN A ROOM.
THEY'VE ALREADY BEGUN TO WORK
BACK.
TO OF.
A QUALIFIED IN A POSITIVE STATUS
INGLEWOOD YOU'RE FAMILIAR WITH.
AND I'M A TALK MORE ABOUT IT IN
JUST A SECOND FURTHER FALLS
UNION OF VERY SMALL DISTRICT IN
BUTTE COUNTY.
TEN STUDENTS.
THEY ARE GETTING FINANCIAL
SUPPORT THIS YEAR AND FORECASTED
FOR NEXT YEAR FROM THEIR COUNTY
OFFICE FIVE OF THOSE TEN
STUDENTS ARE IN SEVENTH GRADE
THIS IS A K. EIGHT DISTRICT. AND
SO THE GOAL IS TO GET THE FIVE
OF THE TEN KIDS OUT.
OF THAT SINGLE SCHOOL DISTRICT
GRADUATED IF YOU WILL FROM
EIGHTH GRADE COMMENCE FROM
EIGHTH GRADE. ARM AND THEN THE
DISTRICT WILL CEASE TO EXIST SO
IT'S NOT ON THE EDGE OF NEEDING
A STATE ALONE EMERGENCY
PREPARATION THAT'S NOT THE PLAN.
IS WOULD BE THE CASE WHERE THAT
THE SCHOOL WOULD CLOSE THE
DISTRICT WOULD CEASE TO EXIST
AND IN NEIGHBORING DISTRICT VAN
WOULD CHANGE ITS BOUNDARIES AND
BEGIN TO SERVE WHAT WOULD BE THE
REMAINING FIVE STUDENTS.
ON THAT WOULD OTHERWISE BE AT
THE SCHOOL.
YOU SOMEBODY I'M GONNA TALK
ABOUT MORE IN JUST A MOMENT.
AT SECOND IN ARM WHICH WERE DO
JUST TWO WEEKS AGO AND SO THE
DATA IS UNOFFICIAL THIS IS OUR
SURVEY OF COUNTY OFFICES BASED
ON DISTRICTS SELF
CERTIFICATIONS.
AND I'VE INCLUDED SOME SUMMARY
DATA HERE BUT THE CHARTS THAT I
ATTACHED TO MY OUTLINE REFLECT
THIS SELF CERTIFICATION AS OF
MID MARCH.
ON YOU CAN SEE THAT THE COURT
NUMBER QUALIFY DISTRICTS IS DOWN
TO TWENTY FOUR.
THERE WERE FORTY ONE A YEAR
EARLIER AND AS I JUST MENTIONED
JUST FORTY TWO A COUPLE MONTHS
EARLIER.
THE COUNTY OFFICES A NEW SHOW
REVIEW INDICATE THAT THERE ARE
ABOUT FIVE POSITIVES THAT ARE
LIKELY TO BE DOWNGRADED TO
QUALIFIED SO WE MAY SEE THAT
TWENTY FOUR GROW. A LITTLE BIT.
WHAT'S NOTEWORTHY HERE'S
OBVIOUSLY THE CHANGE FROM FIRST
AN ARM TO SECOND IN A ROOM AND.
AND THEM THE MAJOR CHANGE IN
DATA THAT WOULD OCCUR AT THAT
POINT WOULD BE THE
ADMINISTRATION'S JANUARY BUDGET
THE GENERAL BUDGET PROPOSAL. I'M
ISSUED BY THE ADMINISTRATION ARM
HAS MORE FAVORABLE TERMS IN IT
THAN DISTRICTS WERE EXPECTING
JUST SIX MONTHS AGO OR EVEN A
MONTH EARLIER. FOR THAT THREE
YEAR WINDOW. AND THEREFORE.
MANY MORE DISTRICTS OF OR
POSITIVE AS OPPOSED TO QUALIFIED
ON BECAUSE OF THE THE
ADMINISTRATION'S BUDGET
PROPOSAL.
THAT SECOND INTERIM THERE ARE
TWO SELF CERTIFIED NEGATIVES
INGLEWOOD A WHICH I'M GONNA GET
TO SHORTLY FEATHER FALLS WHICH I
JUST EXPLAINED TO YOU.
THERE IS ONE DISTRICT THAT IS.
QUALIFIED LIKELY TO BE
DOWNGRADED TO NEGATIVE IN FACT
WE HAVE SEEN THE DRAFT LETTER
JUST IN THE LAST.
DAYR SO.
AND THE COUNTY IS I'M GOING TO
BE DOWNGRADING THEM TO MAKE IT
EVEN I'M GONNA TALK ABOUT THAT
DISTRICT COMES BICU SOMEBODY
I'M A TALK ABOUT THEM MORE IN
JUST A MOMENT.
THAT GIVES YOU A SENSE OF WHERE
DISTRICTS ARE OF BOTH IN
DECEMBER IN THEIR OFFICIAL
REPORTING AND. AT LEAST IN OUR
INITIAL SURVEY OF THEIR
REPORTING THAT OCCURRED IN THE
MONTH OF MARCH OBVIOUSLY
IMPROVEMENT.
AS I'VE ALREADY INDICATED
DRIVEN PRIMARILY BY.
THE BUDGET PROPOSAL THAT WAS
RELEASED IN JANUARY.
SCHOOL DISTRICT FISCAL
EMERGENCIES.
WANT TO TALK SPECIFICALLY ABOUT
INGLEWOOD AS YOU KNOW WE'RE IN
YOUR FIVE AFTER A EMERGENCY
APPROPRIATION.
ARE. OUR ANNUAL FIELD WORK IN
INGLEWOOD.
HAD COMMENCED A MONTH AGO. YEAR
OF FAMILIAR WITH THE
REQUIREMENTS IN THAT IS THAT
FIVE WE REVIEW FIVE OPERATIONAL
AREAS FISCAL FACILITIES.
HUMAN RESOURCES GOVERNANCE AND
COMMUNITY RELATIONS AND PUPIL
ACHIEVEMENT. OF EACH YEAR AND
RIDE A FAIRLY EXTENSIVE REPORT
ON THAT THAT'S RELEASED.
OVER THE SUMMER WE HAVE
COMPLETED OUR FIELD WORK FOR
THREE OF THOSE AREAS STUDENT
ACHIEVEMENT.
.
HUMAN RESOURCES AND GOVERNANCE
AND COMMITTEE RELATIONS WE SEE
IMPROVEMENT IN ALL THOSE AREAS.
HUMAN RESOURCES HAS BEEN OUR
AREA WE'VE SEEN DRAMATIC
IMPROVEMENT OVER NOW SEVERAL
YEARS IN A ROW.
GOVERNANCE AS AND COMMITTEE
RELATIONS I'M CONTINUING TO
APPROVE THIS IS OUR FIRST YEAR
AND FIVE REVIEWS THAT WE'VE
SEEN.
THE NEEDLE MOVE SLIGHTLY ON
STUDENT ACHIEVEMENT.
A LOT OF WORK YET TO BE DONE BUT
WE ACTUALLY SAW ON SOME GLIMMERS
OF OF THE STANDARDS THAT WERE
LOOKING. FANTASY AS WE VISITED
CLASSROOMS
HOW WE ARE IN THE DISTRICT NEXT
WEEK TO BEGIN OUR REVIEW FOR
FINANCE SAYS AN AREA THAT THE
DISTRICT HAS STRUGGLED MIGHTILY
AND. AND FACILITIES BOTH AREAS
OF SIGNIFICANT I'M STRUGGLE FOR
FOR INGLEWOOD UNIFIED IN THE
LAST NUMBER OF YEARS. I'M
OBVIOUSLY FINANCES WHAT GOT HIM
IMPART.
TO TO BE ON THIS LIST TO START
WITH ON WE DO EXPECT TO SEE
IMPROVEMENT IN THOSE AREAS BUT
WILL WILL HAVE A BETTER SENSE
HERE IN THE COMING WEEKS.
DISTRICTS THAT ARE AT RISK OF
TALKED ABOUT THE NEGATIVE
SPECIFICALLY.
INGLEWOOD IN FEATHER FALLS I DO
WANT TO SPEND.
A MOMENT ON.
THREE ADDITIONAL DISTRICTS
WITH RESPECT TO.
.
THEIR STATUS THE FIRST ISSUE
SOMEBODY. ARE WHICH AT SECOND.
BOTH AT FIRST INNER MAN SECOND
IN ON THE DISTRICTS CERTIFIED
QUALITY QUALIFIED THE COUNTY HAS
DOWNGRADED.
TOO NEGATIVE ON THIS IS US A.
K. TWELVE DISTRICT ABOUT FORTY
EIGHT PERCENT AND DUPLICATED IN
ROMAN OF TWENTY ONE
KIDS GENERAL FUND BUDGET OF
ABOUT EIGHTEEN MILLION DOLLARS.
OBVIOUSLY WE ALL KNOW WHERE YOU
SOMEBODY'S LOCATED EASY
LANDMARK.
FOR ALL OF US.
AT THE REQUEST OF THE MADERA
COUNTY OFFICE OF GET COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENT THICK MATS HAVE
INTERVENTION STAFF PRESENT IN
THE DISTRICT.
OF SEVERAL DAYS A WEEK FOR OVER
TWO MONTHS AND WE WILL BE
RETURNING AGAIN.
FOR SOME ASSISTANCE HERE IN THE
COMING WEEKS THE DISTRICTS
CRITICAL LEADERSHIP STAFF WERE
ALL NEW TO THE DISTRICT OF EARLY
IN THE YEAR. AND.
NOT EVEN HALFWAY THROUGH THE
YEAR THEY HAVE ALL DEPARTED.
SO.
OBVIOUSLY SUPERINTENDENT
BUSINESS STAFF AND SO ON ARE ALL
IT STARTED THE YEAR ALL KNOWN AS
NEW ON THEY HAVE ALL NOW LEFT
AND THERE IS INTERIM STAFF IN
PLACE.
IN THE DISTRICT.
AN INTERIM SUPERINTENDENT IN OUR
BUSINESS OFFICIAL.
THEY'RE A GREAT DEAL OF WORK
HAS BEEN ACCOMPLISHED IN THE
LAST SIXTY DAYS FINAL
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE FISCAL
RECOVERY PLAN IS UNDER WAY. THE
DISTRICT SELF CERTIFIED AS I
MENTIONED QUALIFIED IT SECOND
INTERIM HOWEVER. I WE DO BELIEVE
IN AND PRETTY SURE THE COUNTY IS
GOING TO DOWNGRADE DOES HAVE
ALREADY SAID COUPLE TIMES NOW.
THE DISTRICT CONTINUES TO HAVE
AN APPOINTED FISCAL ADVISER BY
THE COUNTY.
WE BELIEVE THE HARD WORK OF
DEVELOPING THE FISCAL RECOVERY
PLAN. THAT WORK IS BEING DONE.
AND ELEMENTS OF IT HAVE ALREADY
BEGUN TO BE IMPLEMENTED THE
ISSUE REALLY THAT'S BEFORE US IS
NOT ALL THE PIECES HAVE BEEN
IMPLEMENTED YET BUT THERE'S
CLEARLY A. A GOAL TO DO THAT THE
DISTRICTS FOCUSED ON THAT A WE
ACTUALLY BELIEVE THAT THIS IS A
DISTRICT THAT IS I'M TURNING
AROUND. ON RELATIVELY QUICKLY
HERE AND AND.
.
PROBABLY WON'T HAVE A NEED TO
REPORT ON IT IN THE FUTURE.
ADDITIONAL DISTRICT THAT IS ALSO
NOT NEGATIVE BUT WE BELIEVE THIS
AT GREAT RISK IS KLAMATH
TRINITY.
.
CLIMATE TRINITY OF ALL ONE OF A
THOUSAND STUDENTS ON K. TWELVE
ALSO EIGHTY FIVE PERCENT AND
DUPLICATED PARA FIFTEEN AND HALF
MILLION DOLLAR GENERAL FUND
BUDGET. WE'VE BEEN PROVIDING
SUPPORT TO THE HUMBOLDT COUNTY
BOMB SUPERINTENDENT SINCE LAST
FALL IN ANALYZING THE DISTRICTS
CASH FLOW.
WHILE THE DISTRICTS GENERAL FUND
OPERATIONS HAVE BEEN STABLE THE
DISTRICT IS IN THE MIDST OF
SIGNIFICANT SCHOOL CONSTRUCTION
AND MODERNIZATION TO MITIGATE
MAULED. IN ALMOST ALL OF ITS
FACILITIES THE DISTRICTS QUALIFY
IT.
FOR AND IS BEEN RECEIVING
SIGNIFICANT HARDSHIP FUNDING
FROM THE STATE ALLOCATION BOARD.
HOWEVER THE DISTRICT HAS NOT
SCOPE THERE CONSTRUCTION
PROJECTS IN LINE WITH THE
FUNDING THEY HAVE OVER SCRIPT
THESE PROJECTS IN THE FUNDING
EVEN AT HARDSHIP BUT HUNDRED
PERCENT. IS NOT GOING TO BE
SUFFICIENT.
TO COVER THE SCOPE THAT THE
DISTRICT SET FORTH.
THIS OBVIOUSLY EXPOSES THE
DISTRICT TO SIGNIFICANT
FINANCIAL RISK AND CASH FLOW
DIFFICULTIES.
THE COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT HAS
PLACED EXPERIENCE SCHOOL
CONSTRUCTION PROGRAM MANAGER AT
THE DISTRICT.
ON TO ASSIST THE DISTRICT AND
PROVIDE ANALYSIS AND COUNCIL WE
THINK THAT PROCESS ACTUALLY IS
GOING VERY WELL.
.
OUR THERE'S OBVIOUSLY STILL
SIGNIFICANT CHALLENGES THEY HAVE
SELF CERTIFIED QUALIFIED AT
FIRST IN A ROOM ON THE COUNTY
DID CONCUR WITH THAT.
SECOND INTERMENT STILL UNDER
REVIEW AND WE DON'T KNOW AT THIS
POINT.
WHERE ON THE COUNTY WILL
ACTUALLY END UP?
?
IT AGREEING OR NOT IT SECOND
INTERMITTENTLY THAT THE DISTRICT
IS QUALIFIED.
BASED ON RECENT CASH FOR
ANNOUNCES THE DISTRICT MAY NOT
BE ABLE TO MEET ITS CASH
OBLIGATIONS WITHOUT SOME
SIGNIFICANT CORRECTIVE ACTION.
AND SO WE CONTINUE TO MONITOR
THAT.
THE THIRD DISTRICT I WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT.
.
HERE ARE BRIEFLY IS OAKLAND
UNIFIED.
THIRTY SEVEN THOUSAND STUDENTS
OF FIVE HUNDRED FIFTY THREE
MILLION DOLLAR GENERAL FUND
BUDGET. I'M K. TWELVE AS YOU
KNOW WHEN AND ROUGHLY SEVENTY
EIGHT PERCENT AND DUPLICATED.
STUDENT POPULATION.
IN. MANY OF YOUR FROM THERE TO
HISTORY IN OAKLAND THAT THEY
RECEIVED A HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLAR EMERGENCY PREPARATION
FROM THE STATE IN TWO THOUSAND
THREE. THE DISTRICT MADE
SIGNIFICANT PROGRESS TO JUSTIFY
THE RESTORATION OF LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHT. THERE IS STILL THOUGH AN
SP I APPOINTED STATE TRUSTEE
WORKING WITH THE LOCAL TEAM IN
OAKLAND.
AT THE REQUEST OF THE DISTRICT
VIC MAC CONDUCT DID A FISCAL
HOUSE HEALTH RISK ANALYSIS LAST
SUMMER. AND CONCLUDED THAT THE
DISTRICT SHOWED SIGNS OF FISCAL
DISTRESS.
AT THE REQUEST OF THE ALAMEDA
COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE FIGMENT
HAS BEEN IN OAKLAND SINCE
JANUARY. PROVIDING TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE IN AN EFFORT TO
ASCERTAIN THE TRUE FINANCIAL
POSITION OF THE DISTRICT FOR
BOTH BUDGET FUND BALANCE AND
ALSO FOR ON CASH FLOW FOR THE
CURRENT YEAR.
WE DID PROVIDE AN INTERIM
STATUS REPORT TO THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE AND A AND A. LARGER
GROUP CD  STATE BOARD STAFF
ON HERE IN THE CAPITAL JUST A
COUPLE WEEKS AGO.
WE HAVE A LOT OF CONCERNS ABOUT
OAKLAND ABOUT THEIR STABILITY ON
FISCALLY.
THEY HAVE.
IN THE MIDST OF CHANGING
LEADERSHIP IN THEIR BUSINESS
FUNCTIONS.
AND THAT'S A POSITIVE THING.
HOWEVER AT THIS POINT IN TIME
WE CONTINUE TO WORK THERE
CONTINUE TO PULL TOGETHER
ADDITIONAL DATA. ON TRYING TO
BUILD OUR CONFIDENCE LEVEL ON IN
THEIR ACTUAL LOCAL MEMBERS.
AND WHAT HOW THEY ARE LEADING
AND MANAGING TO THOSE NUMBERS
WE'VE FOUND GAPS IN THE NUMBERS
OF WHAT. THEY THOUGHT THINGS
WERE COMPARED TO WHAT THEY
REALLY ARE. ALMOND SO WHERE
HIGHLIGHTING THOSE FOR THEM SO
THAT THEY CAN ADJUST ALONG THE
WAY.
.
WHILE WE'VE NOT COMPLETED OUR
HOUSES ARE PLANNER CONCLUSION IS
THE DISTRICT DOES HAVE
SUFFICIENT CASH.
ON RESOURCES FOR THE CURRENT
YEAR THROUGH JUNE.
BUT IS.
.
IN FISCAL DISTRESS AND MUST TAKE
SIGNIFICANT CORRECTIVE ACTION TO
STABILIZE ITS FUND BALANCE.
AND CASH FLOW FOR SUBSEQUENT
YEARS WHEN WE ENTERED THIS.
IN JANUARY WE WERE ACTUALLY
CONCERNED THAT THERE WERE
QUICKLY RUNNING OUT OF CASH
WHICH OBVIOUSLY TRIGGERS
THE WHOLE STATE. EMERGENCY
PORTION MATT HOWEVER THIS WOULD
BE VERY UNCHARTED WATERS WHERE
THEY HAVE AN EXISTING EMERGENCY
PORTION.
AND SO WE BELIEVE THE DISTRICT
CAST SUFFICIENT CASH RESOURCES
BY.
WE'VE DISCOVERED A NUMBER OF
THINGS WHICH ARE ADVERSE TO
THEIR FUND BALANCE.
AND AND THOSE ARE THINGS WE CAN
DEAL WITH OVER TIME OBVIOUSLY
CASH
SHORTAGES NOTS IS AN IMMEDIATE
ISSUE AND SO FROM THAT
STANDPOINT.
THE DISTRICTS IN BETTER SHAPE
THAN WE THOUGHT IN OTHER
RESPECTS IS ABOUT ONE THE
DISTRICT.
IS STRUGGLING A BIT.
SOLVENCY TRENDS I'M JUST TO
TOUCH ON A COUPLE THINGS IN THE
OUTLINE.
ELEAZAR.
CONTINUE TO FACE COST PRESSURES
INCLUDING PENSIONS AND SPECIAL
EDUCATION ALL TOPICS THAT THIS
BODY IS IS CLEARLY AWARE OF.
AND SHOULD BE NO SURPRISE THERE.
JANUARY BUDGET PROPOSAL HAS OF
RT MENTION PROVIDES ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES TO MITIGATE THESE
PRESSURES.
I'M ONE TIME FUNDING PROVIDES AN
OPPORTUNITY TO MITIGATE KNOWN
ADVERSE TRENDS IN DISTRICTS IN
THEIR PLANS. AND SO WHILE I'M
ALL MONEY IS GOOD MONEY.
FOR SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
OBVIOUSLY THEY THEY APPEAL ON
TO THIS BODY ON A REGULAR BASIS
THAT MORE OF IT BE ONGOING
VERSES ONE TIME. IN NATURE
HOWEVER ARE POINT WOULD BE
SIMPLY THAT ONE TIME MONEY DOES
PROVIDE OPPORTUNITIES TO HELP
MITIGATE.
EVEN SOME.
RECURRING I'M OBLIGATIONS.
MULTI YEAR PROJECTIONS SHOW A
DEFICIT TREND AFTER EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN.
AND SO THE LONG TERM
PERSPECTIVE IN A DISTRICT IN ITS
WITH ITS LEADER GOVERNANCE AND
LEADERSHIP TEAM IS ABSOLUTELY
ESSENTIAL.
COST CONTAINMENT IN THE NEW.
WORLD OF AL CAPS DOES LOOK A
LITTLE DIFFERENT THAN IN PAST
TIMES WE'VE MADE VERY PUBLIC
COMMITMENTS.
ON THROUGH THE EL CAP PROCESS
AND SO WHERE THE DISTRICT
CHOOSES TO.
EMPLOY SOME COST CONTAINMENT
MEASURES.
REALLY NEEDS TO BE DRIVEN BY
THAT AL CAPP PROCESS IN THAT
VERY PUBLIC AND OPEN DISCUSSION
ARMED WITH ITS STAKEHOLDERS.
A WE BELIEVE THE AL CAPP
ACTUALLY PROVIDES. A GREAT
BENEFIT AS A TOOL TO HELP BRING
FOCUS
IF YOU HAVE LIMITED RESOURCES
THE ELF CAP PROCESS ON REALLY
HELPS YOU TO FOCUS ON WHAT
YOU'RE GONNA SPEND THOSE
RESOURCES ON. I'M SPECIAL AS YOU
LOOK OUT INTO THE INTO THE
FUTURE YEARS.
CHANGE TOPICS I'M VERY BRIEFLY.
AND TALK ABOUT AB ONE THIRTY
NINE EXTRAORDINARY AUDITS THAT
AS YOU'RE AWARE.
THE STATUTE PROVIDES.
EACH OF THE FIFTY EIGHT COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENTS AND EXCLUSIVE
AUTHORITY.
TWO WHEN AN ALLEGATION OF FRAUD
MISAPPROPRIATION OF PUBLIC
FUNDS.
OR OTHER ILLEGAL FISCAL
ACTIVITIES AS ALLEGED IN A
SCHOOL DISTRICT OR CHARTER
SCHOOL THEY HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO ON CALL UPON US. I'M TO DO
THAT PULMONARY INVESTIGATION AND
OUR THRESHOLD.
IN DETERMINING WHETHER THERE'S
EVIDENCE OR NOT BY THE SUPPORT
THOSE ALLEGATIONS IS RELATIVELY
LOW WE ISSUE A REPORT.
AND THEN THE COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENT UNDER CODE HAS.
RESPONSIBILITIES TO ADVISE THE
STATE.
VARIOUS PARTIES HERE AT THE
STATE AND ALSO THE LOCAL
DISTRICT ATTORNEY OF THE
FINDINGS IN OUR REPORT.
THE NUMBERS GENERALLY HAVE BEEN
IN THE SEVEN EIGHT NINE TEN
RANGE OVER MANY YEARS OF HOW
MANY OF THESE WE DO HERE. AND
I'VE ACTUALLY GIVING YOU THE
HISTORY FOUR SEVEN NINE SIX AND
TEN.
IN THE CURRENT YEAR.
THERE WERE NOT COMPLETE WITH ALL
THE OTHER NUMBERS ARE PRESENTED
HERE ARE COMPLETE YEARS BUT IN
THE CURRENT YEAR WE ARE UP TO
SEVEN.
I'M SORRY WE'RE UP TO NINETEEN
REQUESTS
I'M IT WAS ONLY SEVENTEEN TWO
WEEKS AGO WHEN I PRESENTED TO ON
THE SAME COMMITTEE AT THE
SENATE.
IN THE SENATE I'M JUST IN LAST
TWO WEEKS TO ADDITIONAL REQUESTS
OF COMMAND.
THIS IS IT THIS IS NOT A TREND
THAT WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE. TOM
NOT A TREND THAT I THINK ANY OF
US ARE REALLY PREPARED FOR. A
WHEN I SPEAK ON A REGULAR BASES.
AROUND THE STATE I AM
DESCRIBING IT.
A LITTLE BIT HERE AS A. A
CRISIS IN ETHICS A CRISIS IN
INTEGRITY.
FOR SEVERAL YEARS THE BULK OF
THESE AUDITS WERE AROUND CHARTER
SCHOOLS HOWEVER IN THE CURRENT
YEAR THAT'S NOT THE CASE.
THE BULK OF THE NINETEEN THAT
WE'RE CURRENTLY INVOLVED IN OUR
SCHOOL DISTRICTS AT REGULAR
SCHOOL DISTRICTS AS WE'VE ALWAYS
KNOWN THEM. ON THEIR ONLY
HANDFUL CHARTER SCHOOLS.
BOTH OF THE.
TO RESET REQUEST IN THE LAST TWO
WEEKS HAPPEN TO BE CHARTER
SCHOOLS.
BUT IT'S A TREND OBVIOUSLY THAT
IS.
A BIT WORRISOME TO ON.
THESE ARE NOT CASES OF.
THE PERSON IN FOOD SERVICE
ACCOUNTS THE CASH.
POCKETING SOME OF THE CASH EACH
DAY AND WALKING OUT THESE THE
COMPLEXITY OF THESE CASES. ARM
ARE OUR INCREASE IN ALONG WITH A
NUMBER OF THESE OUR CONFLICTS OF
INTERESTS.
BETWEEN BOARD MEMBERS BETWEEN
SUPERINTENDENT AT THE VERY TOP
OF THE ORGANIZATIONS.
CONFLICTS WITH CONTRACTORS
AND THOSE TYPES OF THINGS TOO
LARGE.
INVESTIGATIONS OR CURRENTLY
INVOLVED IN INVOLVE A. MULTI
MILLION DOLLAR BOND PROGRAMS.
WHERE THERE WERE CONFLICTS OF
INTEREST POTENTIALLY IN HOW
CONTRACTS WERE?
?
CONFLICTS OF INTEREST IN HOW
CONTRACTS WERE AWARDED IN THINGS
LIKE THAT.
LEADERSHIP AND GOVERNANCE AN
INTERNAL CONTROL ISSUES.
REALLY ARE AT THE CENTER OF
THESE.
THEY INVOLVE BOTH THE GENERAL
OPERATIONS OF THE DISTRICT AND
BOND PROGRAMS AS ABILITY TO.
AND.
THEY OUR GENERATING THE
ATTENTION NOT ONLY OF OF FOLKS
HERE IN THE CAPITAL BUT THEY'RE
GENERATING THE ATTENTION OF
STATEWIDE LAW ENFORCEMENT AND
FEDERAL LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES
AND ACTUALLY. A WE'VE BUILT A
VERY STRONG PARTNERSHIP.
WITH BOTH STATE AND FEDERAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT IS SOME OF THESE
MATTERS.
HAVE
HAVE THEM CONTINUED.
WITHOUT.
CHAIR BE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE.
WITH THE CITY OF FIRST OF ALL
LET'S TAKE ROLE. FOR REAL QUICK.
IT'S MCCARTY.
HERE.
CHAVEZ THERE AMONG.
MEDINA.
FOR SITTING HERE.
O'DONNELL.
OBERNOLTE.
OKAY AS TO MY TEACHING THANK YOU
NOT MUCH CHAIR THANK YOU MISTER
FINE FOR YOUR PRESENTATION. SO.
IT IS IT TO.
FAIR TO SAY THAT OVERALL THEY
THAT THE TREND.
WITH THE.
NEVER EVER SINCE THE RECOVERY
FROM THE GREAT RECESSION.
HAS BEEN POSITIVE IN TERMS OF.
DISTRICTS INDEED.
QUALIFIED AREN'T NEGATIVE HAS
BEEN DECLINING.
SO WITH RESPECT TO QUALIFIED YES
WE'VE SEEN KNOW A LITTLE BIT OF
AN UP TICK IN THE LAST COUPLE
YEARS SAYS BECAUSE REMEMBER
LOOKING AT A THREE YEAR WINDOW.
AND SO IS WEEKS AS WE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS ARE FORECASTING OUT
FULL IMPLEMENTATION OF LCF AS WE
KNOW IT.
THEN OBVIOUSLY THERE ARE
UNCERTAINTIES THAT FOLLOW THAT
FULL IMPLEMENTATION RIGHT WE
KNOW CURRENT LAW SAYS THE.
INCLUDE THAT IN THEIR IN THEIR
MULTI YEAR FORECASTS.
SO FOR QUALIFIED QUALIFIED IF
YOU LOOK OVER HISTORY THERE'S A
CHART IN YOUR PACKAGE.
QUALIFIED TENDS TO MOVE WITH
THE STATE BUDGET I'M GOOD YEARS
AND BAD YEARS OF OF STATE
REVENUES.
YOU HAVE.
MORE QUALIFIED LESS QUALIFIED
RIGHT.
WITH RESPECT TO NEGATIVE THERE
ARE SO MANY MORE ISSUES AT HAND
IN A DISTRICT THAT CERTIFIED
NEGATIVE.
THERE ARE CLEARLY GOING TO BE
GOVERNANCE ISSUES LEADERSHIP
ISSUES AT ALL LEVELS I'M IN THE
DISTRICT IT'S NOT JUST A FISCAL
THE DETERMINATION MAY BE A
BOTTOM LINE. DOLLAR NUMBER BUT
BUT THE CIRCUMSTANCES OF A
NEGATIVE AND SO IF YOU LOOK OVER
TIME NAY NUMBER NEGATIVE
DISTRICTS ARE ACTUALLY FAIRLY
CONSISTENT THERE ARE VERY LOW
NUMBER. ON IN PART BECAUSE AB
TWELVE UNDER PROCESS WORKS
ON ANY IN PART BECAUSE IT'S NOT
JUST A FISCAL TRENDING. MATTER
THAT THAT INFLUENCES NEGATIVE
SO.
WITH THANK YOU FOR.
PLANNING S..
DIRECTING US TO THE CHARRED SO
ACTUALLY FOR OUR FROM SIXTEEN
SEVENTEEN.
IT AND THERE IS A INCREASING
TREND AND THE NEGATIVE.
SIR.
OR OR QUALIFY CERTIFICATIONS
BUT AS OF NOW.
BE PROJECTED QUALIFY
CERTIFICATION THERE'S A DIP FROM
FORTY TWO TO TWENTY FOUR.
THAT'S CORRECT BETWEEN BETWEEN
FIRST AND WHICH WAS DECEMBER.
AND THE INITIAL REVIEW OF SECOND
AND ARM WHICH WAS MARCH AND AND
THAT'S LARGELY THROUGH. THE
GOVERNOR IS.
.
FAST TRACKING THE FULL FUNDING
OF THE.
.
LCF A FUNDING.
THE BIGGEST SINGLE IMPACT IN
THAT CHANGE WOULD BE THAT YES
SIR ALRIGHT.
PHAM BUT I ALSO NOTICED THAT.
.
THAT.
MANY OF THE DISTRICTS THAT
YOU'D.
HIGHLIGHTED AS AS BEING GUY
EITHER AND NEGATIVE TERRITORY
OR.
.
PERHAPS HEADED TO OR DISTRICTS
AT RISK.
.
THEY WERE.
LARGELY DISTRICTS THAT HAVE A
HIGH ON DEPLETED STUDENT
POPULATIONS.
SO AND SO ON.
WHILE THESE DISTRICTS ARE
GETTING.
.
MORE DOLLARS UNDER THE LCF A
FUNDING FORMULA.
THEY.
THAT HAS NOT TRANSLATED INTO.
.
HEALTHY.
STABLE BUDGET SITUATIONS IS IS
THAT FAIR TO SAY.
AT LEAST FOR THESE OF THE
DISTRICTS THAT YOU HIGHLIGHTED
PS AND FOR THE DISTRICTS ARE
HIGHLIGHTED.
.
SO WE GO BACK A LITTLE BIT IN
HISTORY SINCE AB TWELVE HUNDRED
IN NINETEEN NINETY TWO.
THEIR BEEN NINE DISTRICTS OF
NEED TO COME TO THE STATE FOR AN
EMERGENCY APPORTIONMENT.
LEADING UP TO THE LEGISLATURE'S
ADOPTION OF AB TWELVE UNDER.
JUST IN THE I THINK THE DECADE
BEFORE THAT THERE WERE SOME
TWENTY.
FIVE IF I REMEMBER THE NUMBER
RIGHT NOW LOW TWENTIES.
AND SO.
THAT IMPART SPEAKS TO THE
PROCESS OF THE LEGISLATURE IN
THE WISDOM THEY HAD AT THAT TIME
PUT IN PLACE.
THAT PROCESS.
.
THE DISTRICTS THAT I'VE
HIGHLIGHTED IN AND LET ME SAY OF
THE NINE THIS IS WHERE I WAS
PROCESS HERE THAN NINE THAT
NEEDED A STATE APPORTIONMENT IT
WAS ULTIMATELY CASH
THE LACK OF CASH WHAT WE CALL
CASH INSOLVENCY THAT PUSHED HIM
OVER THE LINE ON A GIVEN DAY.
WHY WE NEEDED TO COME TO A
LEGISLATURE FOR AN EMERGENCY
APPORTIONMENT?
BUT THERE WERE YEARS AND YEARS
AND YEARS OF LEADERSHIP AND
GOVERNANCE ISSUES THAT PREDATE
THAT SINGLE EVENT.
THE DISTRICTS I HIGHLIGHTED HERE
HAVE LEADERSHIP HAD IN THE NEAR
TERM.
RECENT PASS LEADERSHIP AND
GOVERNANCE ISSUES.
WHICH WHILE THERE WHY THEY'RE
ON THE LIST.
AND SO. I WOULDN'T.
I'D BE CAREFUL WITH THE ONES WE
HIGHLIGHTED TO SAY.
.
THAT DESPITE AND EXPANSION OF
OF REVENUES DURING THE ECONOMIC
RECOVERY AND THE IMPLEMENTATION
OF ALL CFF.
THAT.
THAT. THAT WAS A POSITIVE
EVENT OBVIOUSLY FOR EVERYBODY.
AND FOR THEM.
BUT IF THE RIGHT LEADERSHIP AND
GOVERNANCE IN THE RIGHT FOCUS
SHOULD THE EL CAP PROCESS ON
STUDENT NEEDS.
AND SO ON ISN'T ALL IN ALL THOSE
ELEMENTS ARE NOT IN PLACE.
THEN EXPENDITURES ARE GOING TO
BE A LINE TO THE RIGHT THINGS.
AND SO.
IN THE ONE CASE.
CLIMATE TRINITY IT'S A
FACILITIES ISSUE NOT OBJECT NOT
OF INSTRUCTIONAL OPERATIONAL
ISSUE.
IN THE CASE OF YOU SOMEBODY
WE'VE HAD SOME BREAKDOWN IN
LEADERSHIP.
IN THE CASE OF OAKLAND WE HAVE A
NEW LEADER THERE SINCE JULY.
DOING GREAT WORK.
BUT WE'VE HAD SOME
INCONSISTENCIES IN OAKLAND OVER
THE LAST
DECADE FROM A LEADERSHIP AND
GOVERNANCE STANDPOINT. AND ALL
OF THAT HAS IS A LEAD TO THEIR
CURRENT SITUATION.
MY ONLY IN RESPONDING TO SERVE
MY MY ONLY POINT REALLY IS THAT
WHILE EACH OF THESE DISTRICTS
WITH HIGH IN DUPLICATED
ACCOUNTS.
HAVE RECEIVED.
LARGER PER DOLLAR.
HOUND ALLOCATIONS APARTMENTS IF
YOU WILL.
TOM THEIR ISSUES ARE RELATED TO
THAT THEIR ISSUES ARE REALLY.
RELATED TO A BIGGER A BIGGER
PICTURE HERE WHO SPECIFICALLY
LEADERSHIP IN CONGRESS.
OKAY AND UP.
SO I WAS ENCOURAGED TO SEE THAT.
AYE AYE REPRESENT.
A PORTION OF LOS ANGELES
UNIFIED AND AND IT APPEARS THAT
THEY HAVE MOVED OFF THE QUALIFY
CERTIFICATION LIST IS THAT
CORRECT.
.
AS YOU KNOW SIR LA IS A UNIQUE
HOUSE UNIQUE.
TWO ITS OWN RIGHT.
THEY'RE CURRENTLY NOT ON THE
QUALIFIED LISTS THEY ARE WORKING
AS YOU KNOW.
THEY'VE BEEN WORKING THROUGH
YEARS OF ISSUES.
.
I DON'T KNOW WHERE THE COUNTY
ULTIMATELY LEAVES THEM IN THEIR
IN THEIR CURRENT REVIEW OF
SECOND INTERIM.
BUT THEY ARE.
ATTACK UNIQUE PROBABLY FROM
EVERYBODY ELSE IN IN. THE RISK
ASSESSMENT THAT'S DONE.
ON.
SO THEY GET THEIR OWN RISK
ASSESSMENT THEY DON'T GET THEIR
OWN RISK ASSESSMENT WE HAVE
STANDARDS AND CRITERIA THEIR
PLIGHT EVERYWHERE.
WHAT IS?
SO THERE'S BOTH IF I CAN.
DESCRIBED THIS WAY THERE'S BOTH
A SCIENCE AND AN ART TO THE AB
TWELVE UNDER PROCESS THE SCIENCE
IN PART IS CONSISTENT.
STANDARDS AND CRITERIA THEY'RE
APPLIED BUT YOU YOU GO TO A
DIFFERENT LEVEL AND DEPTH.
WHEN YOU'RE WHEN I COUNTIES
RECESS US ASSESSMENT OF A GIVEN
DISTRICT THAT THERE'S A HIGHER
RISK.
SO TO NEIGHBORING DISTRICTS
COULD HAVE THE EXACT SAME
STUDENT POPULATION EXACTS IN
FUNDING.
ONE MAY HAVE SOME HIGHER RISKS
THAN THE OTHER.
BECAUSE OF HISTORY COULD BE
LEADERSHIP HISTORY COULD BE
GOVERNMENT'S HISTORY COULD BE.
ARMED A WHOLE VARIETY OF THINGS
COULD BE FACILITY CHALLENGES IN
THE CONDITIONS OF THE
FACILITIES.
AND SO THE DEPTH AT WHICH A
COUNTY OFFICE DOES THAT IS
UNIQUE.
AND IT AND SHOULD BE.
VERY CANDIDLY.
BUT THEY ARE FOLLOWING THE SAME
SET OF CRITERIA AND STANDARDS
THAT ALL FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES
FALL.
DURING.
BUT MY MY POINT ABOUT OLLIE IS
THE ARE UNIQUE THEY ARE NOT
COMPARABLE.
TO ANYBODY ELSE IN THE STATE
FROM.
.
JUST COMPARING APPLES TO APPLES.
JUST PURELY BASED ON SIZE
AND COMPLEXITY OF THE DISTRICT.
OKAY.
ONE OF THE CONCERNS THAT I'VE
BEEN HEARING OF BOTH FROM LARGE.
URBAN DISTRICTS LIKE LA UNIFIED
AS WELL AS.
.
SMALLER DISTRICTS IS.
AND THAT.
INDEED THE BASE GRAND PORTION
OF THE LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING
FORMULA HAS HAS BEEN.
.
INADEQUATE ESPECIALLY IN
ADDRESSING THE. AT THE TO.
BIGGEST DRIVERS OF COST
INCREASES PENSION COSTS AND
SPECIAL EDUCATION COSTS.
ARM.
PRIOR TO THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED
FULL.
AN EXPEDITED FUNDING OF LC FFI
IT WAS HEARING.
THIS WITH MORE URGENCY.
ARM.
IT INDEED DO YOU DO YOU HAVE ANY
THOUGHTS AS TO WHETHER YOU.
I MEAN WILL WE ALL KNOW THAT
WE'RE DUE FOR A.
RECESSION AT SOME POINT AND THAT
WE ARE READY.
I HAD BENEFITING FROM.
THE LONGEST.
POST WAR.
EXPANSION AND IN THAT WERE DUE
FOR A RECESSION.
I ES DE YUBA. DO YOU HAVE ANY
THOUGHTS IN TERMS OF.
.
THE PROJECTED TREND.
IN.
NEGATIVE ARE. CERTIFICATIONS
RELATIVE TO THIS ISSUE OF THE
ADEQUACY OR INADEQUACY OF THE
BASS GRANT.
SO I THINK IT'S BEST THAT I
LEAVE IT A DISCUSSION ABOUT THE
ADEQUACY OR INADEQUACY OF THE
BASS GRANT TO MY COLLEAGUES IN
FINANCING ELIO I THINK THEY
HAVE.
A CONVERSATION WITH THEM OVER
THAT WOULD BE.
FAR MORE PRODUCTIVE.
WITH RESPECT TO TREND THOUGH.
WHEN WE WHEN DISTRICTS ARE
PREPARING THEIR MULTI YOUR
FINANCIAL PROJECTIONS THIS
SPRING WHICH WOULD INCLUDE.
NEXT.
THE BUDGET YEAR PLUS TWO
ADDITIONAL YEARS THERE'S NO
DOUBT THAT THEY ARE STARTING TO
TREND DOWNWARD IN YEAR OVER YEAR
REVENUE GROWTH. WHILE
EXPENDITURE GROWTH IN SEVERAL
CRITICAL AREAS IS TRENDING
UPWARD. YOU MENTION AND TWO OF
THOSE PURGED TERROR SPECIAL AT
THREE OF THOSE REALLY PENSIONS
AND SPECIAL ED. OR TWO ON THOSE
ARE CLEARLY.
AS YOU KNOW.
ARE INCREASING.
.
WHILE REVENUE YEAR OVER YEAR
REVENUES NOT NEGATIVE YEAR OVER
YEAR REVENUE IN THE OUT YEARS AS
MUCH FLATTER. LITTLE SOFTER AND
SO THAT WILL DEFINITELY HAVE AN
IMPACT GOING FORWARD ON THE
NUMBER OF QUALIFIED DISTRICTS I
DON'T KNOW THAT WILL IMPACT THE
NUMBER NEGATIVE AGAIN. BUT
DEFINITELY QUALIFIED IT WILL.
.
THE SAME DISTRICTS HAVE RECEIVED
A LOT OF ONE TIME FUNDING.
SIX PLUS BILLION OVER THE LAST
FIVE YEARS HOW THEY'VE USE THAT.
HAVE THEY USED IN THAT TO
MITIGATE SOME OF THOSE LONGER
TERM OBLIGATIONS SUCH AS
PENSIONS AND SO ON. ALSO AS PART
OF THAT EQUATION HAS TO BE
LOOKED OUT SETS UP IT'S A BIGGER
ANALYSIS THAN JUST THE BASE
GRANT.
IT'S A BIGGER ANALYSIS BUT IT'S
FAIR TO SAY THAT.
WE CAN REASONABLY EXPECT.
AN INCREASE INCREASING TREND
AND QUALIFIED CERTIFICATIONS.
FOR SCHOOL DISTRICTS BASED ON
CURRENT FORECAST YES AND IT
WON'T TAKE AS THE LA O. IN
FINANCE BOTH HAVE. SPOKEN TO
HIM.
IN.
.
IT WON'T TAKE MUCH OF A
RECESSION.
IF YOU WILL OUR OUR ADVERSE
IMPACT ON STATE REVENUES TO.
.
TO HAVE THAT.
SAME INFLUENCE ON THAT TREND.
ARE.
THANK YOU.
THINK I WANTED TO ASK THEM SOME.
QUESTIONS SYSTEM I KNOW EVERY
DISTRICT IS DIFFERENT AND THEIR
CIRCUMSTANCES ARE ARE UNIQUE.
HOW THEY GOT HERE BUT AFTER
DESPITE INTERESTING THAT YOU
KNOW WHAT I'VE BEEN IS MY FOURTH
YEAR HERE?
AND.
I THINK THE LAST FIVE OR SIX
YEARS WE'VE HAD AT. UPTAKE IN
PROP NINETY EIGHT FUNDING
SCHOOLS ARE DOING BETTER AND SO
FORTH.
AND SO YOU SAW THAT THE NUMBER
OF THE OF THE THAT DID.
DISTRICTS HIGHLIGHTED IN THE M..
AND THE PROBLEM AREA WE'RE GOING
DOWN AS WE START PUTTING MORE
MONEY OUT THE DOOR TO OUR
SCHOOLS AND THEN THE LAST FEW
YEARS. THEY'VE.
GOT UPGRADED NEXT YEAR YOU
PROJECTED TO GO BACK DOWN.
HOW DO YOU? HOW DO YOU RESPOND
TO THAT AND THIS SEEMS
COUNTERINTUITIVE?
IT DOES I THINK IT'S.
SO FIRST REMEMBER THAT THESE
EVALUATIONS ARE DONE ON THAT IN
A THREE YEAR WINDOW.
SO FOR EACH OF THE POINTS THAT
YOU'RE REFERRING TO SIXTEEN
SEVENTEEN AND AND SO ON. YOU'RE
LOOKING AT THAT CURRENT YEAR
PLUS TWO ADDITIONAL YEARS IN
THAT EVALUATION AND SO WITHIN
THAT WINDOW.
OF THREE YEARS AND AND THE
REASON YOU SEE THE TREND THAT
YOUR YOUR.
REFERRING TO MISTER CHAIR IS.
IS ACTUALLY A FAIRLY SHORT
PERIOD OF TIME.
BE GOES JUST BACK A YEAR TO THE
FIRST ENORMOUS SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN
ONE WHICH UP FROM FOURTEEN TO
THIRTY ONE. THAT BEGAN TO.
LOOK AT WHAT WAS THEN EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN. NINETEEN TWENTY. ARE
WITH WHY WE WERE STILL ON TRACK
FOR A EIGHT YEAR IMPLEMENTATION
OF LCF HALF NOT AN ACCELERATED.
IMPLEMENTATION.
AND SO IN THOSE IN THOSE LATER
YEARS YEAR TWO ONE THREE IF I
CAN REFER TO THEM THAT WAY.
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN NINETEEN
TWENTY YOU SEE.
COSTS RISING FASTER.
THEN YEAR OVER YEAR REVENUE.
SO AGAIN EURO YOU'RE REVENUES
POSITIVE GROWTH NOT NEGATIVE
GROWTH.
HOWEVER THE COSTS
WERE RISING AT A HIGHER RATE.
AND SPECIFICALLY.
AS I WAS JUST ALLUDING TO
PENSIONS.
SPECIAL ED.
AND.
NOT REALLY HIGHER RATE BUT A
COMPONENT OF ALL THIS WOULD BE
STEP IN CALLING. ON SALARY
SCHEDULES IF YOU TAKE JUST
THOSE.
JUST THE FOUR ELEMENTS OF STIRS
PURRS.
STEPPING COLUMN.
WHICH IS THOSE AUTOMATIC TYPE
OF.
PROGRESSIONS ON AS OUR SCHEDULE
FOR YOU BASED ON YEARS OF
SERVICE ARE EDUCATION ATTAINMENT
AND SPECIAL ED AND SPECIAL IT'S
GOING TO VARY WIDELY BY
DISTRICT.
AHMED AL OR EXPLAIN THAT JUST A
SECOND YOU LOOK AT JUSTICE FOR
ELEMENT MOST DISTRICTS WOULD
DESCRIBE THOSE ELEMENTS AS
SOMETHING NOT UNDER THEIR LOCAL
CONTROL.
RIGHT WHERE EVERYTHING ELSE IN
THERE BUDGET WORLD IS KIND OF
UNDER THEIR LOCAL CONTROL IS TO
TO EXPAND PROGRAM ACTS TO EXPAND
PROGRAM WHY. DO WE ADD TEN
ADDITIONAL COUNSELORS THAT'S THE
LOCAL SCHOOL BOARD ON HAS THE
ABILITY TO DECIDE THAT. THE THE
PURSE RATES THE STIRS RATE
STEPPING CALM COURSE WAS. PUT
GUY SET IN STONE NEGOTIATED IF
YOU WILL. DECADES AGO. AND THEN
THE VERY BOND SPECIAL ED IS THIS
IN YOUR OFTEN THEY WITH THIS A.
B. SIX A TWO WHICH IS STATE
MASTER PLAN FUNDING FOR SPECIAL
ED. IS BASED ON TOTAL
ENROLLMENT.
TOTAL ENROLLMENT IN FIFTY
PERCENT OF OUR DISTRICTS IS
ACTUALLY DECLINING.
BUT THERE SPECIAL ED POPULATIONS
NOT NECESSARILY DECLINING AT THE
SAME RATE IN FACT IN MANY CASES
IT'S INCREASING OR REMAINING
FLAT SO AS A PERCENTAGE OF
ENROLLMENT IT'S ACTUALLY GOING
UP. IT'S BEEN BETWEEN TEN AND
ELEVEN PERCENT FOR MANY MANY
YEARS AND IT'S ACTUALLY STARTING
DECEPTIVELY.
INCREASE.
AND START DIXIE BILL ELEVEN
PERCENT. MARK OF ENROLLMENT SO.
WHILE SPECIAL ED REVENUE THEN IS
DECLINING BASED ON TOTAL
ENROLLMENT SPECIAL IT COSTS ARE
NOT NECESSARILY DECLINING.
AND THAT'S PART OF THE EQUATION.
OKAY THANK YOU QUESTIONS MISTER
CHAVIS.
STRONG TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION HOW YOU FIND THIS
VERY.
INTERESTING I'M EVER THE FIRST
ONE I TENANTS SIX YEARS AGO.
AND SEEING HOW YOU USE.
HOUSE GOES.
.
YEAH IT'S ONE OF MY CONCERNS AS
FAR AS THE PENSIONS AND SPECIAL
EDUCATION.
I THINK THE COMMON I'LL JUST
MAKE ON THAT IS.
I THINK WERE.
WE'RE SEEING SOME LOT OF GROSS
IN THE.
THE QUALITY OF OUR EDUCATION I
HOPE WE CONTINUE TO GO THAT WAY
SINCE MY LAST YEAR. SIMMONS
BRIEF I WOULD. HOPE THAT THE
LEGISLATORS WOULD.
LOOK AT THE CONTINUE INVESTMENT
IN EDUCATION SO WE DON'T GO
THROUGH THIS AGAIN.
AND.
EVEN THOUGH THEIR WE MAY BE A
DOWN ECONOMY. THAT WE WOULD MAKE
A EDUCATION A PRIORITY MUCH
BEYOND THE FIFTY PERCENT THAT WE
FOR SOME REASON WE MADE THAT
ARE.
SCHILLING RATHER THAN THE FLOOR.
THAT'S REPUBLICANS SAY THAT BY.
GET THAT DOWN YET OKAY. YEAH.
YEAH.
HOPE YOU GUYS ARE FOLLOWING ME.
THE.
.
THE GOVERNMENTS IN THE COMMUNITY
RELATIONS COMPONENT YOU TALKED
ABOUT LEADERSHIP.
HAVE YOU SEEN THAT IMPROVE
BECAUSE OF HEALTHCARE.
HE MENTIONED DEL CAB BRIEFLY BUT
HAVE YOU SEEN THAT.
A PROCESSES WE LAID OUT IS I
NOTICED WE JUST WE STARTED THE
LOW CONTROL FUNDING INTO
DEVELOPMENT OUT CAP. AS I WAS
TALKING TO SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN
FACT ONE OF MINE IS HERE.
.
THE.
IN MY ESTIMATION.
GOING OUT TALKING TO PARENTS AND
COMMUNITIES AND BUSINESS OWNERS.
THIS PARTICULAR SCHOOL DISTRICT.
DID NOT DO IS ROBUST SAID NOT
REACH.
AS THE OTHER NEIGHBORS SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AHEAD OF MY DISTRICT.
SO FROM YOUR PERSPECTIVE LOOKING
AT A MACRO SENSE.
CAN THE EL CAP REALLY BE A
POSITIVE THING TO MAKE SURE WE
DON'T HAVE.
ISSUES.
I THINK THEY'LL CAP IS A VERY
POWERFUL AND POSITIVE TOOL
THAT'S BEEN INDUCED ARM IN SOME
RESPECTS ARM I THINK IT'S KINDA
SAD THAT. IT TOOK THE
LEGISLATURE TO. TO DO THAT
INCOME OF FOUR STEP PROCESS ON
ON LOCAL SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
SO IN MY EXPERIENCE BOTH IN A
DISTRICT BEFORE I CAME TO FACT
MATT ANTS IN MY TIME IT TOOK ME
OUT.
THE EL CAP.
PROCESS ONE DONE IN AN
AUTHENTIC WAY.
REALLY AUTHENTIC.
ENGAGEMENT WITH.
PARENTS TEACHERS CLASSIFIED
FOLKS BUSINESS LEADERS IN THE
COMMUNITY GOVERNMENT LEADERS IN
A COMMUNITY.
.
STUDENTS AND REALLY STUDENTS AT
ALL LEVEL NOT JUST HIGH SCHOOL
BUT STUDENTS AT ALL LEVELS.
IS.
ABSOLUTELY INCREASES
COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT.
COMMITTEE RELATIONS.
THERE'S ONE. THE.
ONE ANY OF US ARE ASKED OUR
OPINION ABOUT SOMETHING THEY
WERE LISTENED TO.
THAT'S GOING TO INCREASE
DIALOGUE IT'S GONNA INCREASE IN
UNDERSTANDING OF PROCESS
SKINNER.
INCREASE ON APPRECIATION FOR THE
CHALLENGES.
AND A CONTRIBUTION TO THE
BENEFITS AND SO ON FOR THE
DISTRICTS THAT ARE DOING THAT
THEY DO IT VERY WELL. ON THEIR
OUT CAPS REFLECT THAT ENGAGEMENT
THAT REFLECT THE COMMUNITY THAT
THE BROADER COMMUNITIES
PERSPECTIVE ON THINGS.
AND THEY'LL LYING THEN THE KEY
TO ALL THIS IS YOUR LINE YOUR
RESOURCES TO CARRYING OUT THOSE
ITEMS.
AND SO IN MY EARLIER COMMENTS
TALKED ABOUT HELLCAT BEING A
TOOL THAT HELPS US FOCUS EVEN IN
A CAR IN A COST CONTAINMENT
ENVIRONMENT. NOT AN EXPANSIONARY
ENVIRONMENT BUT A COST
CONTAINMENT ENVIRONMENT THE ALL
CAPS A TOOL THAT WILL HELP
DISTRICTS FOCUS. ON WHAT IS
IMPORTANT WHAT ARE THEY GONNA
INVEST IN TODAY THAT'S GONNA
MOVE THAT NEEDLE. IN A POSITIVE
DIRECTION FOR KIDS WITH THEIR
ACADEMIC SOCIAL EMOTIONAL
WHATEVER THE METRIC IS THAT
WE'VE ASSIGNED THAT WE'VE
IDENTIFIED TO THE EL CAP
PROCESS.
IS OUR PRIORITY IT WILL HELP
THEM MOVE THAT NEEDLE AND SO ON
IT IT HELPS FOCUS THAT. THAT
INVESTMENT OF THE DOLLARS THAT
WE GET.
AND I THINK IF YOU LOOK AT THE
SCHOOL DISTRICTS ARE LIKE A
THOUSAND TWENTY FOUR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS IN THE STATE. AND SO
WE HAVE THE SMALL NUMBER THAT.
HAVING DONE I'D BE INTERESTED TO
SEE NOW HOW DID THEY DO IN THE
EL CAP AND USER. EVERITT
RELATIONSHIP THERE AND FTL CAP.
IS HIGHLIGHTED AS A SOLUTION.
THEN IF WE FOCUSED ON ON THAT
PROCESS.
THEN WE COULD EVEN SEE A DROP
DOWN MORE SIGNIFICANTLY.
BAR THE ISSUE OF US NOT FUNDING.
THE SCHOOLS REGARDLESS OF
ECONOMICS.
THE.
AB ONE THIRTY NINE.
EITHER TRENDS
YOU'RE CONCERNED ABOUT GOING UP
UP ENOUGH RIGHT.
IS THIS ISSUE THIS IS A SOFT
REPORTING EFFORT IS IN THAT THEY
GET IDENTIFY HEY WE MAY HAVE A
PROBLEM OR YOU GET WIND OF IT TO
A HOTLINE BINGO. RACE DOWN THERE
HOW DOES THIS HAPPEN SO THIS IS.
AT THE COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT
LEVEL. SO AN ALLEGATION IS
BROUGHT FORTH TO THE COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENT.
IN THE COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT.
KIND OF DIGS AROUND A LITTLE
BIT TO ASCERTAIN THE CREDIBILITY
OF THE ALLEGATION.
AND THEN.
ASSUMING THAT THEY WANT THEY
BELIEVE THE ALLEGATION HAS SOME
MERIT.
THEN THEY HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO CALL UPON US WHAT THEY GET
THROUGH THE FORMAL AB ONE THIRTY
NINE PROCESS THROUGH THICK MAT
IS.
THE TEAM THAT WE ASSEMBLE TO GO
DO THE INVESTIGATION OUR SCHOOL
EXPERTS AND FRAUD EXPERTS OVER
HALF OF OUR STAFF ARE CERTIFIED
FRAUD EXAMINERS.
IF THEY COME INTO OUR AGENCY
WITHOUT THAT CERTIFICATION WE
HELP INVEST
FOR THOSE WANT TO MAINTAIN A
BALANCE OF OUR STAFF BUT THEY'RE
ALL. THEY ALL HAVE SCHOOL
DISTRICT BUSINESS EXPERIENCE.
AND SO THEY GET.
SPECIALISTS IN THOSE AREAS WERE
GOING TO INVESTIGATE A BAR
ALLEGATION AROUND A BOND PROGRAM
THEY'RE GONNA GET SOME OF OUR
STAFF WHO HAVE EXPERIENCE
RUNNING. BOND PROGRAMS AND
FACILITY PROGRAMS IN THE
DISTRICT ALONG WITH.
THE FISCAL AND FINANCIAL AN
INTERNAL CONTROLS AND THOSE
KINDS OF THINGS.
THAT'S THE VALUE OF THAT PLUS
THE COST TO DO THAT
INVESTIGATION ARE REIMBURSED BY
THE STATE.
WE ARE ONLY I CAN ASSURE YOU
THIS WILL ONLY SEE AND HEAR
ABOUT THE TIP OF THE ICEBERG ON
THESE BECAUSE MOST OF THESE
INVESTIGATIONS. ARE INITIATED BY
THE LOCAL DISTRICT.
THEY DON'T REACHED THE COUNTY
OFFICE THE COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT
OF SCHOOLS THE DISTRICT HERE'S
AN ALLEGATION ABOUT A GIVEN
EMPLOYER OR ISSUE. THEY INITIATE
THEIR OWN PERSONALITY VESTED
CATION THEY MAY HIRE A LAW FIRM
OR OR FORENSIC ACCOUNTING FIRM.
WANTED TO HELP THEM WITH THAT
PROCESS AND THEN THEY TAKE THE
ACTION.
THAT THEY'VE THEY TAKE WHATEVER
CORRECTIVE ACTION AND AND.
FOLLOW UP ACTION
AND IT DOESN'T INVOLVE THE
COUNTY SUPERINTENDENTS OF THIS
PARTICULAR SECTION OF THE.
STATUTE IS ON. A FORTY FOR THE
FIFTY EIGHT COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENTS HAVE A TOOL ON
THAT WHEN THEY RECEIVE AN
ALLEGATION.
THAT THEY CAN CALL UPON US AS A
RESOURCE.
WITH I THINK TWO EXCEPTIONS
THIS PAST YEAR WE'VE DONE ALL OF
THE WORK IN THOSE TWO EXCEPTIONS
ONE. WE HAD A CONFLICT WE ARE IN
THAT DISTRICT RIGHT NOW
ASSISTING THEM IN ANOTHER AREA
WE WERE COMFORTABLE THAN DOING.
A FRAUD INVESTIGATION THE SAME
TIME SO WE REFERRED THAT OUT TO
A.
.
THE COUNTY OFFICE ACTUALLY.
HIGHER DAY ACCOUNTING FIRM WITH.
.
FRAUD EXPERIENCE DOWN TO
ACTUALLY CONDUCT THAT WORK.
AND WE WILL WE WILL ULTIMATELY.
THE USING THE STATE FUNDS THAT
WE RECEIVE FOR THAT PURPOSE PAY
FOR THAT WORK ON THAT'S BEEN
DONE. SO THE COST REIMBURSEMENT
FROM THE STATE. SO YOUR BUDGET I
THINK MY NOTES ARE SHOWN THAT
YOU HAVE A.
FIVE POINT THREE MILLION DOLLARS
BUDGET.
WITHIN THAT.
IT'S WITHIN THAT FIVE POINT
THREE OR IS IT SEPARATE NOTES
WITHIN THAT FIVE POINT THREE.
IT'S IN ADDITION TO OUR BASE
ALLOCATION OF THE TWO POINT NINE
THERE'S A SEPARATE ALLOCATION
FROM. THE ORIGINAL AB ONE THIRTY
NINE. WAS ORIGINALLY.
.
CHOOSE BACK WAYS BUT WAS
ORIGINALLY CREATED AS A
CATEGORICAL PROGRAM AND THEN IN
THE.
THE COLLAPSE OF THE CATEGORICAL
PROGRAMS UNDER LC FF IT REMAINED
A SEPARATE FUNDING ITEM OUT
THERE.
SO IF I'M A FIXED AMOUNT I'M A
SUPERINTENDENT IN A FIGHT. HERE
AT ISSUES OF LICIT CONTRACT
ISSUES.
FIVE GO OUT AND HIRE SOMEBODY
WITHIN THE DISTRICT TO DO THE
AUDIT. IT KEEP IT WITHIN THE
HOUSE.
I AS A SUPERINTENDENT I GUESS
WOULD HAVE TO PAY FOR THAT
OUTSIDE OUT.
YES FORTIFY IS A SUPERINTENDENT
SAY YOU KNOW WHAT I'M GOING TO.
HIGHLIGHT THIS TO MY COUNTY.
IN THE COUNTIES THAT HAVE YOU
COME IN.
THEN YOU DO IT AND THE STATE
PAYS FOR.
AND THEN I AS SUPERINTENDENT
DON'T HAVE TO PAY THE MONEY FOR.
WHAT IT IS THAT CORRECT?
SUCH.
THAT'S ALL CORRECT.
IT'S NOT AN AUTOMATIC PROCESS
THERE'S A. ON INITIAL ENGAGEMENT
IN THAT CONVERSATION.
TRYING TO REALLY DETERMINE.
THE MERIT OF THE ALLEGATIONS OF
THE NATURE OF THE ALLEGATIONS
AND THOSE KINDS OF THINGS IN
MANY CASES.
THE ALLEGATIONS COME WITH A
VERY.
WITH A LOT OF EVIDENCE.
I MEANS I THIRD PARTY IS MAKING
ALLEGATION THEY SEND YOU THE
DOCUMENTS THAT THAT DO THAT.
WE WOULD OFTEN SAY TO COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENT POINT WE'RE NOT
GOING TO ADD VALUE TO THIS
PROCESS WHAT'S HELP YOU REACH
OUT TO YOUR LOCAL DISTRICT
ATTORNEY. HAVE THEM US IN THEIR
PUBLIC INTEGRITY UNIT HAVE
ASSIGNED INVESTIGATOR AND AND DO
THE WORK AND AND AND WE DON'T
THEN GET INVOLVED.
IN SOME CASES THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY THEN COMES BACK AND
SAYS.
WHILE THIS IS SOME SPECIALIZED
AREA THAT. WHILE WE GET THE
BASICS WE NEED SOME ASSISTANCE
IN THAT CASE THE COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENT MAY TURN TO US TO
HELP.
THE HELP DIG UP THOSE THOSE
SPECIFICS SO WHEN YOUR PRE NOT
THIS COMMITTEE BUT IN THIS ROOM
RIGHT FOR. YOU.
COMMENCE THIS HEARING WAS A
PREVIOUS WAS ANOTHER HEARING.
AND THERE'S A COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENT.
THAT TESTIFIED WHO I THINK IS
STILL SITTING BEHIND ME.
DOCTOR WHITE FOR RIVERSIDE
COUNTY.
WHEN SHE RECEIVED AN ALLOCATION
AND AN ALLEGATION ON A COUPLE
DIFFERENT THINGS IN THIS PAST
YEAR.
SHE DID SHE AND HER STAFF DID
THEIR HOMEWORK. TO DETERMINE.
KIND OF THEIR CONFIDENCE LEVEL
IN THAT IN THAT.
ALLEGATION AND THEN REACHED OUT
TO US FOR ASSIST.
THANK YOU FOR THAT EDUCATION AB
ONE THIRTY NINE HITS AS VERY
GOOD THANK YOU SIR FOR YOUR.
PRESIDENTIAL. THANK YOU DO WE
HAVE PUBLIC COMMENT.
SEEING NONE THIS IS IT
INFORMATIONAL ITEM.
THANK YOU FOR THE ANNUAL UPDATES
AND FOR YOUR SERVICE.
FOR OUR SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND
SCHOOLS ACROSS CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU.
YEAH